pitt et robert rochefort bonjourbonjour
économistes député européen
vice-président du modem
alors après ce rejet massif claire et
nette des grecs aux plans d'aidé
européens
est-ce que l'espoir pour vous d'un
accord est il toujours envisageable
quand on écoute avec ses 6 prince il dit
je vais m'atteler à négocier dès
aujourd'hui d'ailleurs regardez je me
sacrifie mon ministre des finances pour
montrer que je donne des gages de bonne
volonté il est très minces très minces
il reste un petit espoir je vais vous
expliquer comment je vois la possibilité
de cet espoir lorsque les négociations
ont été rompues
finalement il y avait dans le texte de
négociation des choses et il y avait
d'autres choses qui n'étaient pas encore
vraiment en particulier l'accord sur la
réduction de la dette
donc finalement monsieur type race a
fait voter sur un texte qui est en deçà
de ce qui était à peu près acceptable
comme compromis
donc là la seule chance est une chance
politique et la politique parfois c'est
de l'habillage la seule science
politique c'est qu'on dise
regardez il ya un nouveau texte ce texte
au lieu d'être un texte de technocrates
technique de 25 pages où on explique des
choses très compliquées
c'est un texte très court il fait trois
paragraphes premier paragraphe
voilà en gros les réformes que la grèce
acceptent de faire ce qu'elle a à peu
près inconscient sur lequel il ya
presque un consensus deuxième paragraphe
oui il y aura une ya une renégociation
d'un décès n'y aura pas dans six mois ou
dans 18 mois il ya tout de suite on dit
oui y'a renégociation de la dette à
l'annulation non annulation c'est pas
possible vos amis auront pas il ya deux
ou trois je veux bien qu'on parle tout
de suite de ça mais il ya de leurs trois
textes et musiques pour faire ça
troisièmement un plan de relance ce que
jean claude juncker avait amené jusque
quelques heures avant qui étaient ces
fameux 35 milliards de relance de
l'économie grecque qui l'avait proposée
est allé sur quelques années alors là
vous voyez ya ce papier ce papier il est
très court
et qu'est-ce qui se passe monsieur type
ghazi regard des victoires j'ai obtenu
un papier sur lequel ça y est c'est
écrit qu' il ya une réduction de la
dette et de l'autre côté les européens
lui laisse un tout petit peu l'idée
visuel de cette victoire et 10 en même
temps en particulier à leurs électeurs
non mais en réalité on était déjà
quasiment d'accord sur ça c'est monsieur
tsipras ce qu'a voulu faire un coup
coupant juste avant voyez sais c'est
qu'au monde et fois au salon c'est une
ligne de crête unis de crète mais vous
m'avez demandé donc je probabilité
probabilité probabilité 10 15% et sinon
c'est m sinon sinon c'est évidemment la
sortie de la grèce de la zone euro et
dans ces cas-là ce que je peux
simplement vous dire c'est qu'il faut
que nous aidions les grecs c'est à dire
que ce n'est pas parce que les grecs
quitterait la zone euro qu'il faut que
nous considérions que nous n'avons pas
un effort de solidarité avec eux ne
serait ce que parce que nous sommes
coresponsables de lézat va faire rentrer
alors qu'il n'était pas en état de
rentrer et nous sommes aussi co
responsable je n'ai franchement de ces
négociations ratées depuis cinq ans nous
avons fait nous les européens un nombre
incalculable d'erreurs dont l'une
d'entre elles était d'ailleurs à mon
avis le fait de mettre le fmi dans la
boue dans la boucle bon et cette
démission j'y reviens de yannis
varoufakis c'est pas un signe de bonne
volonté
si vraiment al-fatwa décès c'est quelque
chose de cela six ainsi bien pourquoi il
fait d'accord mais tu allais soyons
clairs
c'est comme je veux dire en france quand
on dit à monsieur sapin qui les
punissent de travail parce qu'il s'est
engagé à inverser la courbe du chômage
était que la courbe du chômage n'est pas
inversée
ça c'est de la petite politique je ne
dis pas je ne dis pas que monsieur type
race a eu tort de le faire mais il ne
faut pas surévaluer l'importance de ce
geste disons c'est un petit élément de
dans la corbeille
il met ce petit ce petit élément
supplémentaire mais il le fait en
premier qu'il le fait en premier oui ça
ne change pas fondamentalement les
choses c'est un élément de communication
monsieur de sipera c il est assez habile
je ne sais pas si au final il aura a
fait plonger son pays dans une
catastrophe incroyable ou s'il aura
réussi à être un homme historique
en tout état de cause c'est un tacticien
on ne peut pas le nier bon et cenon
tracleer des grecs pour vous c'est
manifestement c'est comme un échec pour
pour merkel qui anticipait quand même
elle tablait sur la victoire du oui pour
se défaire de type race avec qui elle a
pu trop envie négocier est ce que c'est
un respect qui l'affaiblît en gamme et
rien ou pas du tout non c'est d'abord un
nom qui nous a fait 10 tous parce que ce
nom il ya trois noms dans le nom il ya
un premier nom qui est un nom économique
c'est-à-dire les grecs disent on ne veut
pas un plan d'austérité supplémentaires
et vous êtes sympas y compris vous les
français de dire qu'il faut qu'on ait la
retraite à 67 ans mais est ce que
monsieur hollande est capable de
proposer aux français dans la retraite à
67 ans premièrement un nom technique
mais c'est la technique forte c'est pas
de la technique
deuxièmement c'est un non politique
c'est à dire c'est grosso modo il ya des
politiques qui maintenant sont étoiles y
est éloigné de nous qui géra notre place
qui s'allie avec des technocrates et
donc un nom pour faire simple contre
bruxelles et contre l'ensemble des
anciens responsables politiques en grèce
il ya un troisième nom qui m'inquiète
davantage
c'est un non contre tous les pouvoirs
établis parce que si vous regardez en
grèce tous les pouvoirs établis disait
qu'il fallait voter oui des syndicats au
patronat aux anciens premiers ministres
donc là il ya quelque chose de beaucoup
plus fort il ya l'expression de la
coupure qui est qui va jusqu'au bout
d'un peuple avec non pas simplement la
classe politique moi je veux bien
entendre politiques dire que c'est nous
les politiques qui recevons des coups de
pied aux fesses c'est beaucoup plus
large que ça se sont dits compris les
leaders syndicaux qui prennent un coup
dans les fesses et donc ça c'est quelque
chose dont il faudra qu'on s'intéresse
pour l'avenir c'est à dire que la crise
entre eux alors on va dire entre les
gens installés
et puis le peuple qui quand je vous dis
ça j'ai presque l'impression de faire un
peu du mélenchon mais mélenchon le fait
simplement sur la politique
moi je le fais sur le la société c'est
l'ancien sociologue qui vous parle et ça
ça me paraît très préoccupante
est-ce que sinon c'est préoccupant de
voir les déclarations du ministre de
l'économie allemand qui dit si prince a
coupé les derniers ponts entre la grèce
et l'europe des réactions très ferme de
berlin qui ouvre la porte l'an que la
cena mois ce qui l'a beaucoup frappée la
semaine dernière à bruxelles
j'étais au parlement européen c'est
d'entendre mes collègues s'exprimer et
mes collègues s'exprimer tous avec la
culture de leur pays
est ce qu'à réussi monsieur de sipera ce
et jeudi réussie entre guillemets c'est
d'exactions exacerbée tellement les gens
que les gens ne se met plus à la place
de l'autre mais il se met à leur place à
eux
autrement dit et ça c'est le drame de
cette négociation raté c'est que les
allemands résonne complètement en
allemand les grecs résonne complètement
en grec alors que quand vous voulez
faire un compromis est quelque chose qui
aboutit à un accord
le principe c'est de vous mettre aussi à
la place de l'interdît moi je suis comme
ça et vous vous êtes comment est ce qui
se passe
soyons clair c'est que les allemands
sont relativement à une très large
majorité derrière une opinion
extrêmement dur de même que par exemple
les lettons qui disent nous nous avons
je prendre cet exemple parce que j'ai un
collègue qui s'est exprimée très
fortement là dessus nous nous avons payé
beaucoup également à cause de la crise
notre pouvoir d'achat a beaucoup diminué
et donc ce que la grèce veut nous
imposer on ne peut pas l'accepter
autrement dit ce qui fait que cet accord
n'a pas eu lieu et c'est compréhensible
c'est parfaitement compréhensible mais
dans la vie quel que soit quelle que
soit comment dire ce que vous voulez
négocier si vous êtes toujours dans
enfermé dans votre propre regard sur
vous même et si vous n'êtes pas capable
de vous de mettre un tout petit peu à la
place de l'autre ça ne peut pas marcher
alors pourquoi on est en est on arrivé
là probablement par l'usure on ne s'est
pas rendu compte que c'est moi et c'est
moi c'est semestre et c'est semestre
ou comment dire on remet ça sur la table
ont dit c'est le seul sommet de la
dernière chance puis s'est jamais le
sommet de la dernière chance ça use
ça use ça use tout le monde et on finit
par être dans une position que je ne
qualifierais pas d'égoïsme
parce que ça ce serait simpliste mais en
tout cas dans une position qui consiste
à se voir soi-même avec sa propre vision
du monde et malheureusement l'allemagne
est effectivement assez cohérente et
assez unie sur le regard qu'elle porte
un rapport à la grèce est ce que le
couple franco allemand sera unis demain
on sait qu'un sommet des chefs d'état et
devrait manquer prévu regard américain
qui sera à paris ce soir c'est là où
tout va se jouer on a vu encore une fois
des divergences d'appréciation entre
angela merkel qui a dit on attend le
référendum et françois ans qu'il voulait
tout de suite trouvé un accord qu'est ce
qu'ils doivent faire
en soirée ce qui doit s'opposer en gala
merkel devant des soldats surtout pas
tendez la nous sommes actuellement en
train de danser sur des braises le feu
peut partir à n'importe quel moment ça
peut aussi bien se passer y compris la
sortie de la grèce de la zone euro
si nous aidons la grèce c'est nous le
faisons d'une façon coordonnée le vrai
danger actuellement c'est une explosion
des chefs d'état et de gouvernement hors
grèce c'est à dire de l'ensemble du
collège de la zone euro pour faire
simple maladresse et ceux qui assureront
la cohésion de cet ensemble c'est
d'abord la france et l'allemagne
donc si la france et l'allemagne
aujourd'hui montrent des divergences
alors là tout péter et donc je crois
qu'ils n'ont pas le droit ils n'ont pas
le droit d'avoir un point de vue
divergents j'ai envie de dire que madame
merkel et monsieur hollande
j'aurais aimé d'ailleurs quand même
monsieur juncker dont l'amour mais ça
c'est une autre sphère mais le couple
franco-allemand c'est faux c'est
fondamental il faudrait ce soir à
l'elysée les enfermer vous savez et ont
dit vous ne sortirez que quand vous
aurez un point de vue unique qui
d'ailleurs sera aussi un point de vue
pour la suite parce que il ya le drame
de la grèce aujourd'hui mais il y a
qu'est ce qu'on fait ce drame de la
grèce qu'elle qu'en soit l'issue pour
faire en sorte qu'ils ne se reproduisent
pas et que l'europe demain soit plus
démocratique et en même temps plus
cohérente bon sachant que l'une des
erreurs ou les volets mentionné robert
rochefort c'est l'idée la
restructuration de la dette grecque qui
aurait dû avoir lieu depuis bien
longtemps même le fmi l'a rappelé la
semaine dernière
d'ailleurs en 2012 les européens avaient
promis qu'ils auraient une
restructuration le jour où il y aurait
des excédents budgétaires avant paiement
des intérêts de la dette en grèce
c'est à ce moment là est venue fin 2014
et puis tu arrives et de strass et vous
savez pourquoi en fait donc les enfants
n'ont pas tenu parole non
laissez pas ça c'est à dire que les
européens ils veulent que l'on accepte
de réduire la dette grecque sans que ça
se voit c'est à dire que c'est un peu
comme pour vous donner une image c'est
pas le même montage mais c'est juste
pour que les gens qui nous regardent et
qui nous écoutent comprennent c'est un
peu comme quand le crédit lyonnais avait
quelque chose de très très grosses
dettes et qu'on a fait ce qu'on appelle
une structure de défaisance vous en
souvenez probablement il faut faire la
même chose à se dire qu'il faut dire
quelque part que cette dette
on n'élimine pas parce que si on les
élimine alors tous les français perdent
l'argent qui est là mais il faut la
cantonner quelque part où les gens qui
sont des experts savent qu'on récupérera
jamais cet argent mais c'est une dette
est une dette inscrite et qui fait qu'on
a toujours d'une certaine façon le
papier un peu comme les emprunts russes
si vous voulez qu'il prouve qu'on a le
droit de faire ça alors évidemment la
perte est réel et vive il faut faire en
sorte que la perte ne soit réel que dans
quelques années et qu'on lis cette perte
dans leurs rangs un certain nombre
d'années il faut au fait il faut sauver
la face il faut aussi rouler il faut
sauver la face à à ceux qui ont prêté de
l'argent et qui aujourd'hui ne peuvent
pas accepter l'idée qu'on leur dise
demain
eh bien vous avez perdu ce que vous avez
prêté parce que dans 20 ans dans trente
ans si cet argent est perdu ben nos
enfants feront avec mais en même temps
il faut évidemment que la grèce puisse
avoir la capacité de ne pas être plombée
par le service de cette dette qui est
impossible à réaliser
seulement on va continuer à en parler
mais d'abord elle vous pas convaincu par
les propos qui sont tenus et porté en
direct boursorama par robert rochefort
convaincus ou pas pas d'accord pas
d'accord convaincus ou pas je vous
laisse voter je donne un résultat dans
dans quelques instants
cette idée que dans un plan global de
négociations entre les européens et la
grèce 6 essayer de reconstruire
l'économie grecque vous l'a évoqué 35
milliards qui étaient manifestement dans
l'accord c'est ça l'idée aussi de
permettre à la grèce de se reconstruire
de sa passe par quoi ça passe par des
baisses d'impôt sur les sociétés par
encourager l'investissement être une
zone franche
ça passe ça passe par le fait pour faire
simple de faire comme on a fait lorsque
l'espagne le portugal sont rentrés dans
l'union européenne c'est à dire qu'on a
injecté massivement de l'argent ce qu'on
continue d'ailleurs à faire en europe
avec les régions qui sont les régions
les moins les moins en situation
économique d'être développés dont il
faut les aider tout simplement en
finançant des projets de développement
dans les territoires donc il faut
rentrer là dedans il ya une autre chose
aussi qui est très importante et qui a
été un des non-dits de toute cette
négociation
c'est le fait que la grèce doit être
aidé dans le fait de se construire un
état on ne peut pas réformer un pays qui
n'a pas d'état et moi c'est une des
choses que je trouvais sur réalise par
exemple quand on négocie la hausse de la
tva alors à la fin on avait le simple
sentiment d'ailleurs que l'accord allait
se faire à 14% ou à 24% sur les îles sur
différents types de choses mais comment
pouvez-vous négocier une hausse de tva
si vous n'avez pas une version fiscale
qui est derrière puis si vous avez une
économie au noir vous voyez bien que le
risque c'était d'augmenter la tva en
ayant encore plus d'économies soccer ce
qui n'aurait rien donné comme résultat
autrement dit ce que nous n'avons pas
non plus compris c'est qu'il fallait un
un plan d'assistance en envoyant en
envoyer un certain nombre de conseillers
techniques pour aider les grecs mais
mais là c'est un chantier beaucoup plus
large
il faut là aussi pour que ce pays et sa
pleine place dans l'europe tout court
et alors a fortiori dans la zone euro il
faut qu'ils soient normalisées
du point de vue de sa culture de l'état
et du point de vue de l'efficacité de
ses services administratifs et ça c'est
un très très très gros chantier
on a eu tort de faire comme si il
n'existait pas oui plus on arrose tout à
fait d'accord mais sur la reuss ou
contre la main pour reconstruire
l'économie grecque parce qu'on voit bien
que même si les coûts salariaux ont
baissé même si le roi baisser les bras
il faut des envies 3 ème art pas ça ne
redémarre pas c'est comme si ce même si
la drachme on y revenez la drachme ça ne
relancerait pas comment ça s'est passé
pourquoi parce qu'il a plus d'industrie
pas comment ça s'est passé en espagne en
espagne ça s'est passé parce qu'une
baisse des salaires et en grèce aussi à
une baisse de salaire
la compétitivité industrie n'est pas le
mien entre les avait totalement raison
grèce vous avez totalement raison
aujourd'hui la grèce tout le monde sait
que son poids économique c'est le
tourisme
d'un côté vous avez aussi de la droite
et 6 points de pib aussi six points vous
avez aussi de l'agroalimentaire et il
faut qu' il y ait de l'investissement
dans certains un certain nombre de
secteurs comme la grèce bien c'est ce
que je vous dis il faut que ce soit il
faut que ce soit fait
le cadre de projets d'investissement
dans lequel l'union européenne se
commande ils s'investissent et puis
qu'il y ait deux un peu comme dans le
plan juncker d'ailleurs pour l'europe
aujourd'hui c'est à dire qu'il y est
l'acceptation d'une prise de risque sont
des investissements qui pourraient
comment dire de ne pas marcher vous
savez l'un des problèmes que nous avons
eu également c'est nous n'avons pas
proposé d' espoir aux grecs
nous avons été trop les européens alors
proposé de la sueur et des larmes
or d'abord ils n'ont jamais compris très
bien jusqu'à quel moment on voulait leur
imposer de la sueur et des larmes
puisqu'il lui différents types de plans
de restructuration mais nous n'aurons
jamais marcher parce que sinon jamais
marcher la dette est toujours même
absolument ils se soient pauvres il est
la situation économique s'est réduite
et aujourd'hui quand on dit que la grèce
était en train de s'en sortir
ce que j'ai entendu beaucoup ce genre de
show fin 2014 non mais c'est pas vrai
parce que immédiatement après l'économie
a rechuté et grasse et quand absolument
et quand on nous dit regardez la grèce
avait un petit excédent petit accident
c'est tout ça c'est de la rigolade la
grèce a commencé à ne plus payer ses
fournisseurs à l'intérieur pour se
retrouver finalement ne même plus
pouvoir non plus payer ses créanciers à
l'extérieur si les négociations ne
devaient pas aboutir d'ici 48 heures 10
ou 15 % de chances qu'elles aboutissent
vous nous dites ça peut continuer à
négocier mais il ya la date butoir du 20
juillet il faut sa victoire le 20
juillet et bien entendu
bien entendu on expliquait alors il faut
expliquer aux gens qui nous écoutent
la grèce doit de l'argent à la banque
centrale européenne mais c'est pas le
fmi non c'est pas le central c'est pire
la banque centrale européenne ne peut
pas accepter que cet argent n'arrive pas
donc la grèce cette fois ci le fmi lui a
des possibilités d'attentes un mois puis
même à la limite deux ans mais la banque
centrale européenne ne peut pas attendre
donc voilà balle
ça tombe ça tombe directement mais si
long que la grèce ne rembourse pas le 20
juillet la ville et ce sera 4 1 en train
d'exiger d'arrêter les prêts et d'exiger
d'arrêter de financer les banques
grecques qui feront de facto file en
voilà mais on vous allez on peut dire
les choses autrement
on peut dire que l'administration
grecque a commencé déjà à faire de la
monnaie non euros c'est à dire que
l'administration grecque est obligé de
payer ses fonctionnaires est obligé de
payer les retraités
or ils n'ont plus d'argent maintenant
ils vont faire dans les prochains jours
eh bien ils vont émettre un papier qui
sera reconnaissance de dette
le ny vola vous donne ça alors est-ce
qu'ils appelleront drague moby c'est
qu'ils appelleront je ne sais pas
comment mais d'une certaine façon c'est
eux mêmes qui vont inventer une monnaie
qui évidemment ne sera absolument pas
reconnu
en dehors des frontières de la grèce
mais que les grecs utiliseront entre eux
entre eux puisque c'est ce que l'état
leur donnera et voyez d'ailleurs d'une
certaine façon que c'est de cette façon
là que la grèce elle-même
sortira sortira hors de la zone euro
mais ce que je vous dis c'est que en
tout état de cause il ne faut absolument
pas dire que le fait que la grèce puisse
sortir la zone euro soit une victoire de
qui que ce soit ce sera une victoire
deux personnes et en tout état de cause
même s'il sort de la zone euro nous
avons un devoir de solidarité avec eux à
voir comment comment les choses peuvent
se faire calmement
ils peuvent sortir de la zone euro tout
en restant dans l'europe ça paraît alors
alors ça c'est hubert védrine affirme et
c'était possible hier soir oui mais il a
raison je veux dire là c'est là où un
moment donné c'est plus les technocrates
qui doivent avoir le pouvoir en disant
regardez dans le texte ce site est prévu
cela etc
il faut que ce soit les politiques les
politiques reprennent la main et les
politiques disent eh bien oui à la salle
ya deux techniques et de technique très
simple
la première c'est de dire elle sort de
la zone euro mais de fait donc en
émettant sa propre monnaie le temps sa
propre monnaie donc on ne l'a presque
pas danser dans quelques jours ça dans
quelques jours donc à ce moment là à ce
moment là on dit bah regardez nous on
n'a pas mis la grèce en dehors de la
zone euro et la grèce n'a pas non plus
un jour proclamer qu'elle était en
dehors de la zone euro mais ça s'est
passé de fait donc et elle reste dans
l'europe
l'autre cas de figure qui est un petit
peu plus compliqué mais qui est plus
légal c'est de dire avec le traité
lisbonne la grèce sort de l'europe sort
de l'union européenne ehret a des
relents
main à l'union européenne mais sans
adhérer à la zone euro donc là on fait
un système honnêtement je préfère le
premier au deuxième mais je vous assure
qu'en tout état de cause s'il ya une
volonté politique pour que la grèce
reste dans l'union européenne et il le
faut pour énormément de raison parce que
ne serait ce que parce qu'il ya plein
d'autres pays qui sont pas dans la zone
euro et qui sont demandeurs dans l'union
européenne
et puis aussi parce qu'il ya un problème
un enjeu géopolitique on ne peut pas
laisser l'adresse aux mains des russes
enfin il ya quelque chose de très
important à réaliser
et puis parce qu'on les aide on les aide
parce qu'il reste dans l'union
européenne
donc je vous garantis qu'on trouvera les
politiques au plus haut niveau
trouveront l'astuce qui permettra à la
grèce de rester dans l'union européenne
tout en sortant de la zone euro
d'ailleurs une sortie qui n'est pas
forcément définitive qui pourra donner
lieu dans dix ans ou dans quinze ans une
réadhésions la zone au bon tout cas
voilà d'ici demain il y aura donc de
main square un sommet des chefs d'état
européens un accord vous semble quand
même possible même si vous n'en serez
dirigé que deux disciplines et il est
très très faible
mais le devoir est effectivement
d'essayer de faire en sorte pour ceux
qui sont aux affaires de le réaliser cet
accord parce que encore une fois moi je
vous savez ça fait plusieurs semaines
que je disais qu'il fallait étudier
l'hypothèse que la grèce sorte de la
zone euro parce que le plan il ya deux
ou trois semaines était pas acceptable
pour les grecs je le dis tout en n'étant
pas du tout du côté de monsieur tsipras
c'est évidemment mais l'ironie de
l'histoire c'est que c'était au moment
où effectivement le plan était en train
de se modifier et de prendre en compte
un certain nombre de choses
indispensables aux grecs
et là dessus je dois dire que jean
claude juncker a joué un rôle
ce qui explique d'ailleurs sa déception
à ce moment là les choses les choses ont
été rompues donc si on remet cela sur la
table avec un peu d'intelligence et de
côté il ya une petite chance mais ne
l'amplifier ont pas mais ne disons pas
non plus que si cette petite chance ne
réussit pas alors la sortie de la grèce
la zone euro et la fin du monde je ne
crois absolument pas que ce soit ni la
fin du monde à se présenter dans les
prochains jours elle se profilera on la
gère aura et voilà et c'est une question
que les grecs auront des difficultés
mais les grecs auront de toute façon des
difficultés bon voila merci à vous
robert rochefort économistes et député
européen
et vice présidente du modem était votre
invité en direction pour ça va merci à
vous et bonne journée